Bonjour bonjour !
Alors c'est ça maintenant ta nouvelle intro ?
Allez on passe à autre chose
T'en pense quoi de ton battle ?
Alors là on gagne les compétitions, on va pas se leurrer
Mais pourquoi t'es aussi sûr de toi ?
Parce que j'ai un ego surdimensionné et j'me fais une fellation chaque soir avant de me coucher
Ouais, t'as pas pris la grosse tête par hasard ?
Absolument pas !
C'est quoi ton astuce pour faire autant de vues sur tes vidéos ?
En fait c'est simple
Faut juste mettre la musique en très bonne qualité, bien enregistrée au montage
Et faire des changements de plans
Et même si c'est nul, ça paraîtra moins nul !
C'est le secret de mes vidéos, c'est que c'est de la merde
Mais vu que je fais des zooms, ça parait beaucoup moins nul
Et quel est le pire commentaire de ta chaine, celui qui t'as le plus touché quand tu l'as lu ?
Commentaire : "On dirait un coton-tige mixé avec une paire de testicules. Je suis désolé mais c'est la vérité"
Ouais, et t'as réagi comment suite à ça ?
Je me suis inscrit à la salle de musculation
Hein
Et c'est sous forme d'abonnement donc tu payes tous les mois pour pouvoir y aller
Et j'y suis allé euh... 5 fois
En 3 mois
Mais ça a poussé un peu, hein
Ben c'est à dire que c'est pas vraiment ton bras, c'est un bras qui sort du moule que j'ai créé, tu vois ?
Aaaaah !
On peut ajouter les muscles nous-mêmes
On peut dire "ici je veux un muscle qui va dans ce sens
Et ici je veux un muscle qui va dans ce sens"
Ouais, c'est exactement ça. Regarde, j'ai plusieurs tests en stock
Ca c'est abusé mec
Allez, j'espère que c'est bientôt la fin parce que je commence à transpirer mon gars
Ok, est-ce que tu aurais alors un petit mot de fin pour la Belgique ?
Ici ! On a la meilleure mousse d'Europe